make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are returning yet again to
the vs series and in this part of the
video or at least this first part we're
covering black widow vs. magic and in
the second fight in this video we'll
cover Colossus versus Ben Grimm so
having said that um this fight between
between Black Widow and and and magic
and even the fight between it will
really it's red hulk and then and then
Ben Grimm and then on several Colossus
and this all takes place in the blue
area of the moon right so this is about
issue number five ah this is again still
the first half of the story right like
Avengers vs. x-men was twelve issues
long so these all these vs. fights take
place within the first six issues and I
think the last one might take place to
the very end I'm off to double check to
make sure but and this fight between
magic and Black Widow is is kind of
interesting here and the reason why is
because one of the things that Illyana
Rasputin really says here is that for
her this is really more of a game and
the reason why is because if it was not
a game
ultimately she would end up killing
Black Widow and that's true let's run
the clock back a little bit right
because we haven't really done a whole
lot of discussion about Ileana so we
can't really just kind of run through
the conversation and call it a day we
kind of have to kind of have to have
this talk
right so Illyana Rasputin originally
appeared well technically she appeared
back in giant-size x-men number one in
1975 it wasn't until 1983 in 1984 that
we got Magic Volume one and that was a
four-issue limited series but what it
was designed to do was basically explain
the nature of her character insofar as
why she has powers and why she's part of
the whole demonic realm and all that
kind of stuff so when Illyana Rasputin
was 6 years old she was basically
tricked and traveling to the realm of
limbo she was more or less taken there
Kitty Pryde in the x-men tried to save
her but ultimately they were
unsuccessful and she was trapped there
for some time with the not really the
leader of the demonic realm well now
that I think about it I guess really
Belasco is the leader of the demon realm
like he has kind of head of the demon
realm but also know he ended up
basically grabbing grabbing magic and
then bringing her to the realm of limbo
and then basically keeping her there
for quite some time now the idea was
that there were other other members of
the x-men who were from other dimensions
who were trapped there as well right so
one thing to understand if you go back
and you read that for issue limited
series it's good but it's also a little
strange so there's kind of prepare
yourself for a little bit of that
strangeness there but at the end of the
day Illyana Rasputin had learned to
fight from a version of Kitty Pryde from
a different dimension who was trapped in
limbo as well as an alternate reality
version of storm who was trapped in
limbo as well ended up being that both
of those characters basically ended up
dying at the
Ilyana although she really kind of had
to you know in terms of saving them from
a fate worse than death basically being
experiments for like all of eternity but
the long and short of it is that she
ended up escaping the realm of limbo if
she was around 13 years old it was kind
of a kind of Marvel's way of explaining
here's why she was six years old like
three months ago and here's why she's
like 13 years old now right because in
the realm of limbo she continued to age
but essentially almost no time it passed
at all in the time that she was trapped
there and the time that she returned now
there are a couple things we will also
talk about here as we get through this
but the overall gist is that when it
comes to the ability of these two
characters to fight Illyana Rasputin is
no match for Natasha Romanov and the
reason why is because I'm Tasha Romanov
is she was trained as part of the Red
Room right so that was Russia's attempt
to basically create kind of like their
own Weapon X program more or less and
they ended up creating the Red Room the
result of this is that she's a
formidable fighter right she's some of
the one of the best fighters out there
this is compounded by the fact that I
believe she was trained by Wolverine at
one point in time and basically taught
how to fight by him either that or she
was taught by her father who in turn was
taught my Wolverine but he was basically
involved in her training in some
capacity she's one of the best fighters
out there in Marvel right so that and
all the various abilities the fact that
she kind of has a serum of sorts it
gives her augmented strength things
along those lines oh she's really head
and shoulders above Illyana Rasputin in
terms of bare bones fighting and this is
when Illyana Rasputin basically uses her
stepping disks now these stepping disks
are and it's one of these things that
model does kind of throws out there and
I don't believe it wasn't really
clarified originally if they were part
of her powers but essentially she can
create these disks now the realm of
limbo is what she has to pass through
right so it's like Nightcrawler right
Nightcrawler wants to teleport from
Westchester New York where the x-men are
to Egypt right he has to pass through
the brimstone dimension and then to
Egypt right he can't just jump from from
Westchester to Egypt doesn't really work
that way he doesn't teleport from one
place to the next
with Illyana Rasputin is the same way
she passes through the limbo dimension
and then in turn ends up at her location
and it doesn't matter what it is it
could be at a different point in time it
could be at a different location on
earth or even beyond the earth right
depending on on who's writing the story
but these stepping disks are basically
what are used that's what you see when
these hands seemingly come out of
nowhere and try to pull a black widow
into them right which they successfully
do the results of this is that it
basically grabs Illyana Rasputin and the
fight really kind of begins to manifest
inside this limbo realm now there's kind
of a difference here like when it comes
to limbo there's true limbo
then there's magics limbo now
limbo is kind of like an ancillary
version of limbo a kind of realm that
she can control unto herself right true
limbo is essentially where they seem to
be in the sense of the entire location
is not bending itself to her win but
magic for the most part isn't really a
friend of the people in limbo right like
these demon entities are constantly on
the prowl to try to kill whoever it is
that they come across and BlackWidow
immediately lets loose right all these
weapons and guns different things like
that so shooting everything up and
ultimately tells tells Ileana get us out
of here like get us out of this realm of
limbo or I will kill you here and you
will die with me in this godforsaken
place now of course if for no other
reason than for self-preservation
Illyana Rasputin gets him out of there
why she teleports them out and then from
there this fight kind of continues with
Ileana summoning the soul sword now the
soul sword is an extension of illyana's
life force right so she basically
channels her life force into the sword
now when it first appeared again
referencing we're really uncanny x-men
number 160 and this Magic Volume one
miniseries this soul sword when it first
manifested was just a general sword but
as Illyana Rasputin began to use it more
and more it began to kind of alter and
take a form that was really more
conducive to how she envisioned it right
so literally the sword grew as she did
as she used it more and more often
that's why like over the course of time
in Marvel Comics you'll probably see
this sword begin to change form over
time because it's a reflection of
Magic's life force but the long and
short of this is that the the soul sword
is essentially deadly to anybody who's a
magic wielder but can also knock
individuals who were non magic wielders
unconscious and that's exactly what
happens to Black Widow she's basically
impaled by the sword
of magic and then in turn she's just
kind of left and knocked out right now
again that's really the only way the
Illyana Rasputin probably could have won
this fight to be honest because she's
just not as good of a fighter as Black
Widow is she's just not on that same
level it just doesn't really work that
way so what we end up doing here is we
jump to the fight between Red Hulk
Colossus and the thing now if we're
being honest with ourselves the fight
between Red Hulk and Colossus kind of
continues on from uncanny x-men issue
number 11 what in truth that fight
really ended more with Colossus giving
the wind to Red Hulk and the reason why
was because that fight took place
underwater at basically the the base of
the mutant city of utopia and the result
was that in the middle as their fight
began that kind of rage basically
Colossus gave in to the power of CID
Iraq insofar as he became as kind of
demonic form the issue with that is he
was fighting with this almost
uncontrollable rage right
it was more than enough to overpower the
Red Hulk the problem was that in the
process he had damaged the pillar that
were supporting you to help you're at
least one of them and the entire nation
would have come crashing down and so it
was one of these things where he just
kind of left himself open to the Red
Hulk the Red Hook understood what was
going on and just started pummeling
Colossus right you started absolutely
thrashing him so that was kind of a
defeat but not really what this gives us
is a straight-up knockdown brawl between
the two and it's very short-lived right
and it's kind of interesting because in
this fight it all takes place on one
page between Red Hulk and unstoppable
Colossus and literally the two of them
are just kind of like fighting like
they're on knuckle fighting just like
ripping each other apart and the funny
thing about it is that Red Hulk kind of
gets the upper hand and says I'm tired
of fighting with you grabs unstoppable
Colossus and basically just like throws
him just just like sends him flying into
a pillar where he comes across Ben Grimm
the thing and so in this little skirmish
here I would give the win to Red Hawk
right because it's not as though
Colossus was holding that it's not like
it was an uncanny uncanny x-men number
11 when he was like I don't want to keep
losing control so just knock me out now
so I don't have to worry about
destroying the pillar that supports
utopia it wasn't anything like that it
was literally the two of them fighting
it seemingly to the best of their
abilities and Red Hulk getting the upper
hand and just kind of throwing him away
and having him come face to face with
Ben Grimm now this fight goes exactly as
you would expect right Ben Grimm is no
match for the unstoppable Colossus and
very very few people are with this whole
thing with Ben Grimm
this fight takes place in a matter of
seconds I would say you know probably in
the span of like maybe a minute and a
half two minutes and the reason for that
is because Ben Grimm is pulling out all
the stops right he kind of has these
funny moments you know where he's like
let me make your bed for you you know
let me fluff your pillows and he's just
like punching you're just pummeling
unstoppable Colossus as best he can but
at the end of the day Ben Grimm just
doesn't have much to offer he can put on
he can put a pummeling on unstoppable
Colossus but it's one thing to be able
to punch a guy it's different to be able
to knock him out and that's really what
goes on here right in terms of
unstoppable Colossus getting the wind
the way this plays out he doesn't really
beat Grimm within an inch of his life or
anything along those lines he actually
plays it smart right because this versus
battle is kind of in the midst of
everything going on so it's one of these
scenarios where both the Red Hulk
unstoppable Colossus and even Ben Grimm
himself are like we don't have time for
this right we got bigger things going on
if you really want to fight that's fine
less in this thing right so Ben Grimm
throws a brick in the mouth of
unstoppable Colossus kind of makes him
choke for a minute and then goes
charging at him and then immediately
unstoppable claw
it's because of the fact that you know
he can't really be moved you know
because he's got the power of the of the
juggernaut in turn he grabs Ben Grimm
and just raises him out outside of the
blue area of the moon and then basically
leaves him there where there's no real
oxygen and Ben Grimm basically passes
out he who's kind of in a weakened state
he gets pulled on by by Colossus and
then basically he's just kind of kind of
knocked out and that's essentially it
right so it's really more due to the
circumstances that Ben Grimm has knocked
out more so than unstoppable Colossus
getting the upper hand on him now to
those people who were gonna ask the
question how are they fighting on the
moon on Earth's moon and Marvel Comics
you have what's called the blue area and
the blue area is a portion of the moon
where there's oxygen that's actually
whether were the watcher resides who
watched The Watcher before he was killed
by Nick Fury that's where he resided
that way that's where his Citadel and
his base of operations was that's where
everybody is right now in Avengers vs.
x-men it's been there for quite some
time and that's why they're able to
fight here but in reality I would again
say that if this fight continued on for
any real measure of time unstoppable
Colossus would have gotten the upper
hand anyway right he would have taken
out Ben Grimm even if it wasn't for
these circumstances so I think we can
all kind of agree with that many of them
strong but he ain't strong enough to be
able to defeat Colossus with the
combined power of the juggernaut just
doesn't work that way well that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explain and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you